we used to look up in the sky wonder
that our place in the Stars I just look
down I'm worried about our place in than
dirt
go for main engine start t minus 10 we
must confront the reality that nothing
in our solar system can help us 9 and
got kids professor how long have you
gone hey I'm asking you to trust me 7
you have to talk to me Murph 6 ain't fix
this before I go I've no idea when
you're coming back five main engines
start can you told her you're going to
save the world no
and you become a period three one thing
comes right clear to
nice that you'll make sure your children
feel safe one
and coming back
I love you forever potentially habitable
worlds right within our reach and save
us from extinction here we go
if you just think about your family now
you have to think bigger than that
I am thinking about my family and
millions of other families
maybe we've spent a long
you're all this how a theory
is the one thing that transcends time
and space
do not go gentle into that good night
old age should burn and rave at close of
day
rage rage against the dying
yes you are
we'll find a way we always have
you